we generally think we understand reality
but when you see something like that
it can make you question that it can
make you suspend your ideas and I think
that's why it's really interesting to me
it's not because you know some people
look at it as oh you know it expands
what's possible but it's morph to me
what's interesting is it gets people to
suspend their ideas about reality and
not to be so sure that we know because I
think we often think that we already
understand reality we think that our
worldview is more or less complete that
maybe there are some things that we
don't know and some things that we don't
understand but more or less we've got a
handle on reality and I like I like to
do what I do because it it brings that
into question and in that creates space
for us to discover a lot more depth
about who we are and why are we here
no I never explain what I do and that's
unique to my style because I like to I
like to I don't tell people whether what
I do is real or not real I like to leave
them guessing and that's part of what
creates this sense of suspension of the
ideas because if I told them that it
wasn't real they'd have some ideas about
it and if I told him that it was real
they would just form some other ideas
about it as well and I like to keep
people perfectly in the middle where
they're not sure and it's much more
interesting
I don't think they're over focused I
mean I think we have certain belief
systems that but I find that people are
remarkably open I've performed for
scientists and I'm always doctors and
I'm always amazed at how open they are I
think it's not that we tend to be
skeptical is we've been given a very
materialistic framework for existence
and we don't yet have a way even when we
experience something non materialistic
whether it's psychic or spiritual which
are two different things if we
experience either of those we don't
necessarily have a conceptual framework
or understanding to to make meaning from
it and therefore it's easier to kind of
dismiss it but I don't think it's that
people necessarily overly skeptical I'm
always amazed at how open-minded people
are